صاحب السمو الملكي الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان وزير الطاقه طبعا بنرحب بحضرتك معنا
في قناه العربيه ايه مبادرتين مهمين جدا
اطلاقهم اييي سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان
قبل عام والان النسخه الثانيه من الطموح
الى العمل ما عليك ذكرت والى التحدي عام
بعد عام مضى ما الذي تحقق من ما كنتم
تطمحون اليه
ولذلك يعني تركت القدره انه اني اقول
من سمعني في في الجلسه او من سواء يسمعني
بعد
انه
بمعنى انجزنا بما ان حققنا شيء ملموس
وقائم وسوي ينفذ وموقع عليه بعقود وهكذا
نعتقد انه نمتلك الجراه الان انه يقول ما
هو بس نفذنا ولكن ايضا ان نتحدى ان من
سيريد ان ينفذ ان ينفذ مثلنا او يعني يكون
احنا لهم الكبه
العالم العالم يعني فعلا في ازمه ازمه
المناخ ولكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه خطط
خطوات كبيره جدا لهذه المبادرات يمكن
استبق الدول الصناعيه وكبيره بما تحققه
فيه
الى من كان يعطيني المحاضرات
عن حجم المبيعثات انظري كم مستوى انبعاثات
الان
وفي الوقت اللي احنا نخفض فيه انبعاثنا
هناك دول
تزداد من بعثاتها وهي الدول اللي كان
يفترض ان تكون صاحبه المبادره
وتملك المقومات سواء الماليه او الفنيه
والقدرات الماليه والفنيه هي الان ااا
تزيد من
انبعاثاتها بينما المملكه وغيرها من الدول
اللي هي اقل
قدرات فنيه وكذا هي واللي هي تتهم اصلا
كانت بانها مصدر الانبعاثاتها
ايضا هناك طموح كبير قوي ما تم تحقيقه من
خفض بعتات من 130 مليون طن الى
للعهد طلب ان يكون اجتماعات تكون سنويه
ولماذا حولت الان تكون متزامنه مع
اجتماعات الكون
لان عندنا اسمه قناعه
مؤيده من جميع الفرق الفنيه ومن يعمل في
هذا المجال لانه بامكاننا كل سنه
همم نيجي في كب القائد مثلا و نعدل
بتحديدا ما تم تنفيذه من نهايه هذا الكوب
الى الكوبي جاي
وكم متواليه ااا نظهر جدياتنا للعالم نظهر
اسبقيتنا في واننا ايضا مقدمين لحلول
ومفاجرين وانه يعني او نعي نعي ما نقول
ونعني ما نقول
لان الطاقه ستكون مستدامه ولكن سيكون
استبدال بالهيدروجين الاخضر والازرق وكما
ذكرت اسمه
في نهايه المطاف ان شاء الله في حدود 20
لن نكون دوله منتجه للطاقه لا
نسال نكون دوله منتجه مصدره للطاقه في
شكلها الشامل بترول سواء الغاز
الطاقه متجدده هيدروجين
نعملك مقاومات انه نكون اكثر الدول الخاصه
قال لها كلفه وبالتالي همم نعتقد عندنا
امكانيه تنافسيه في انه نصدر طاقه لا نسجل
فقط
يمكن يكون موجه لدول يعني التي فيها بعض
الفقر بتعتمد على الوقود وعلى الفحم ولكن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه خطط خطوه يمكن
غير مسبوقه في هذه
فينا بما نشاطات متعدده بس احنا نحاول
نكون مجمعين لهذه النشاطات لانه موضوع
الحقيقه اذا جانب اخلاقي انساني وايضا
جانب موضوعي انه عشان نقدر نعالج موضوع
الانبعاثات لازم
نوسع من مناطق الخضراء في العالم وايضا
نساهم في تقليص ما يبدل الان في للاسف في
تقليص هذه المساحه الخضراء
والتقليس هذه مساحه الخضراء اللي يحصل
الان في العالم هي في مناطق محدده يغلب
عليها الفقر وكل القدره وكل الامكانيات
وهذا اللي يجعل النقاش النقاش هذا اكثر
اهميه يعني دول صناعيه
حاولوا تساعدوا هذه الدول وهذه المجتمعات
فان تحصل على طاقه مصادر الطاقه نظيفه حتى
تتوقف عمليه الاحتقاب حتى
تتوقف عمليه
تقريص المناطق الخضراء اللي تنتج عن عمليه
الاحتقاب
والاثر الانسان الاخر لا يكون لن يكون اقل
اهميه والمحافظه على صحته من يضطرون الى
هذه الوسائل لانه لاحد لهم ولا قوه
عندنا برنامج الان نطبقه نطبقناه مع
صندوق اوبك وصناديق اخرى مشتركه معه
امس كنت حضرتي
ابتدينا مع مدغشقر ونايجر ونيجيريا وغانا
بس والسنغال ودول افريقيا كثير لكن ايضا
عرفت النظر انه هي ليست ضروري الافريقيه
فقط في
الهند الباكستان بنجلاديش سريلانكا
كمبوديا فيتنام في ايضا في دول امريكا
اللاتينيه يمر بنفس الظروف عندما نرى انه
الدول الكبرى اللي هي مسؤوله عن اكثر
انبعاثات الكربونيه لم تفي بتعهدتها منذ
كوبنهاجن 100 مليار ولا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الان او بعد عام همم بهذه
المبادرتين يعني
بكل ما تسعى اليه همم كما ذكرت ما هي
الاستثمارات في المناخ التي تنتويه او
بدات في فعل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وجزء منها انفاق حكومي وجزء منها مشاركات
دوليه في مجموعه كبيره اعتقد انا ما بحب
اذكر ارقام ولكن رقمه رقم ما هو خصوصا
بجانب الاستثماري فيها لكن يعني خلينا
نؤكد على حاجه واحده
انه ما التزمنا فيه
بحلول 20 30 سوف يتحقق
ما يمكن ان نلتزم فيه
ونكون عندنا نفس الموثوقيه والمصداقيه
فينا نقول نجي وكذا للعالم جهارا لانه سوف
نلتزم بهذا سوف نلتزم بهذا نحن دائما
نتوقف
عند موضوع واحد هو موضوع المصداقي
المملكه
والى الان لا تذكر شيء ولا تلتزم بشيء الا
اذا كانت هي متاكده كانت دوله حكومه انه
قادر على التنفي لانه موضوع المصداقيه
واعز علينا بكثير واهم علينا بكثير وهذا
ذكرت اننا سن سائل العالم
سالنساء العالم لانه احنا سننفذ ما يطلب
منا
وما التزمنا به لكن ايضا نريد ان نساعد
الاخرين ماذا فعلت
وخصوصا في الموضوع اللي انت حكيت فيه
اليوم 100 مليون مليار وينها
اسالي
كل من كان يريد ان يستفيد منها
اين المئه مليون
بعضها ذكره انه اي دوله او حكومه او شركه
في دوله ما
نقول فيه في اي دوله افريقيه مثلا
اقترضت قرضا
من بنك
سيسجل هذا على انه جزء من 100 مليون
اترك التفسير لك
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان وزير الطاقه احنا بنشكر سمو جدا على
هذا اللقاء وبنثمن على كل ما تقومون به من
جهد واحنا بنعرف انه فعلا انه عملته يعني
مبادرات واعمال غير مسبوقه بنراها الان
بتتحقق على ارض الواقع
ان شاء الله القادم افضل
لكن ايضا كل مره اخرى لن نلتزم بشيء الا
احنا واثقين بمشيئه الله قدرته ان قادرين
عن النفس وبذا سوف نكسب المصداقيه وبذا
سنكون لنا ان شاء الله رياده في هذا
الموضوع